[موسيقى]
اذا عبد الله القرني معانا هنا في هذا
الاستديو الخارجي لصباح العربيه من هنا في
العلا يسعد هالصباح يا عبد الله يسعد
صباحكم
اليوم صباح العربيه اييه بصراحه شكرا
لوجودك معنا
عبد الله انت فنان من
اهل الت
لحيت عاصفه الجبال
تحفه فنيه
فحتى اللي مو مبدع بصير ممتع سواء في
العزف او بالتلحين او حتى باي مجالات اخرى
يعني حتى بالتصوير في مصورين يعني بالعلا
ما شاء الله تبارك الله
فقط هذا
بيئه ملهمه جدا عبد الله انت من فتره كنت
ترند
بل
انا في حفله محمد عبده في مسرح مرايا
قبل لا يخلص باخر اغنيه سبقته الى المطار
والحمد لله يعني كنت من اول مستقبليه
[موسيقى]
والحمد لله كانت من اجمل اللحظات
يعني يسلمو انا لك يا عبد الله عبد الله
اليوم من ضمن مخطط رحله عبله زمان في
اهتمام بالفنون بشكل كبير جدا وجعل العلا
ايضا جاذبه ووجهها سياحيه من خلال الفن شو
هي جهود الهيئه الملكيه لدعم الفنون
ما قصروا يعني كل يوم نشوف شيء دعم جديد
وشيء جديد
على الصعيد الثقافه وعلى الصعيد التطويري
بالعلا يعني سمو الامير بدر ما قصر اي شيء
وعلى راسهم كمان ايضا ساعات المهندس
الاستاذ عمره مدني يعني هو بنفس الطريقه
وبنيه تحتيه والاهتمام حتى بجد بالسياح
فهذا الشيء يعني ما شاء الله تبارك الله
نحسد عليها هنا
بالتوفيق عبد الله كمان راح نسمع منك
معزوفه المستمعين في حابين نسمع لفيروز
بما انه نحن في الصباح صباح العربيه بس
قبل ما نسمع لفيروز عبد الله بدي اسالك عن
عملك الخاص للعلا يعني احنا قليل ما سمعنا
اغاني او معزوفات تخص العلا بالتحديد بشكل
خاص
ان شاء الله انا شغال على موضوع اغنيه
خاصه للعلا خاصه بعد تصنيفها الان من
عجائب الدنيا السبعه
شغال على الموضوع بجديه كبيره طبعا العمل
بيكون من من
كلمات الشاعر الكبير يزيد من خالد
والمغني الى الان قاعدين نبحث عن مغني
بحيث انه لابد انه نظهر بشيء يليق بالعلا
والتاريخ العلا وبفن العلا بالتوفيق
[موسيقى]
يعني يسلمو هالايدين يسلموا هالقنابل فعلا
اطربتنا على الصبح يا عبد الله وعبد الله
انت اسمك الفني ملهم احنا بنشكرك جزيل
الشكر على وجودك معنا ونورتنا هنا صباح
العربيه